overworked underpaid
and traumatized healthcare workers from
around the world have borne the worst of
the coronavirus pandemic
from the constant threat of infection
every day when i go to work
i feel like a sheep going to slaughter
to the daily onslaught
of death i cried in the corner
i couldn't take hearing anything more
about covet victims because in the end
they were also my victims in a way
the toll has left many disillusioned and
in need of
urgent help themselves
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin thanks for
joining us
risking their lives to help others
survive that's the title of a revealing
and
quite disturbing survey among healthcare
workers who say
during this pandemic they face
harassment and violence because of their
profession
what's wrong with us with society to
attack those who put their lives at risk
to help
and care for others lots to talk about
after this report from spain
the atmosphere at the corona ward of
zendal hospital in madrid
seems almost relaxed right now
many beds are empty at the moment
the days have again become a bit more
bearable
she and her colleagues live through the
worst of the pandemic
it has left them deeply traumatized
maybe nothing i fell into a big hole
i cried in the corner i couldn't take
hearing anything more about covet
victims because in the end they were
also my victims in a way
then last february and march 400 people
would die every day
that was devastating many were already
desensitized at that point
but of each of these 400 i can give you
at least two or three names and
the names of the children for me these
are not numbers
it also weighed on her that for months
she could not see her
daughters to avoid possible infections
hernandez blanco is now
in therapy it helped me to understand
that no one outside our field can really
understand what we have lived through in
here
it wasn't told and we also don't want to
talk about it
many colleagues in the hospitals in
madrid share that opinion
the experience was too traumatic
first studies show that at least 40
percent of medical professionals
need a psychological assessment and some
experts even think that there's already
another pandemic
that will soon spread worldwide the one
that affects mental health
in seizure arrange hospital 500 out of
8500 professionals require
extra help for instance in the
psychiatric ward
which has set up special support groups
we already put preventive groups in
motion before it all escalated
these are groups where people can talk
about their experience
so you have doctors nurses helpers and
one of our psychologists who share what
they're worried about
between the frustration of not knowing
how to use their expertise like under
normal conditions and not knowing what
you deal with
a huge scar has developed and it's
putting a strain on medics
laura's sons this strain forced her to
leave her job
the intensive care medic contracted
covet 19 and then went back to work in
the icu
despite suffering from long covert
we're not superheroes when you work in
the intensive care unit you're used to
24
48 or 72-hour shifts almost without a
break
without help you are strong you can do
that and all of a sudden you can't
anymore
then it's time to look for help
i went to work crying then at work i saw
how the nurses would cry in the kitchen
or where the patients were
the situation was desperate i found them
like this
i cried with them and then i cried on my
way back home in the car
at some point i said to myself it cannot
go on like this
it's a decision she doesn't regret many
of the affected medics are now
processing what they have witnessed they
hope the long queues at spain's
vaccination centers will keep the beds
at the icu free
so they will really have time to heal
and for more i'm joined by christy
hoffman general secretary at uni global
union which represent workers in the
skills and services sectors including
health
very good to have you with us uh we're
not superheroes
that was just uh mentioned in the report
uh that
showed the difficult situation for
hospital nurses in
spain you serve at 3 000 health care
workers mostly working
in long-term care like nursing homes how
does
their situation compare
well monica thanks for having me on your
show
unfortunately what we found is that the
situation for long-term care
is similar to the to the that that you
just heard from these spanish workers in
acute care
really so many are uh
subject to low pay understaffing stress
at work
no ppe mental health um so
you know 75 percent said that low
staffing levels
hurt their ability to give good care
half a majority said their wages were
not high enough
so that they could afford just basic
basic
things that you need to live housing and
food and transportation
and a third believe it or not still
don't have access to ppe's um
even worse in some of the hardest hit
countries but fully a third
well into this pandemic still don't have
ppe so
mental health crisis across the industry
violence and harassment
and just the crushing burden of caring
for people without a break the demands
of the demands of time uh stress
it's it's been quite an ordeal for these
workers right and your survey
uh it was actually looking at 3 000 or
even more healthcare workers in
37 countries are there regional
differences
well across the board
across the countries where we represent
workers and in these 37 countries
the the problems are all too common
everywhere
i think that we could say there are some
exceptions
for those countries and regions that
have strong
collective bargaining on a sectoral
basis like for example austria where
there is a way
to manage the conditions at work uh in
those countries for example the us
where there is either no bargaining or
at best
some isolated facilities here and there
uh that that
um where workers have the right to
bargain in that situation
um that that could be the worst um or
where there's just simply no bargaining
and no resources in the sector so
i think it ranges um a little bit
and we do say some some uh uh austria is
doing better or
like austria with sectoral bargaining
but still the problems are pervasive
right i mean if you just add it up
underpaid overworked exposed to disease
and
even harassed uh do you think there'll
be anyone left who wants to take up a
career in healthcare in the years to
come and if so what needs to be done
in order to ensure that you know the
reality is
workers are leaving care the the care
sector in droves
this is a real problem because the more
workers leave the more
the burden increases on the existing
workers so you've identified a really
good problem
because obviously the care as the
demographics change
care sector is going to be a growing
part of our economy we
need a strong and well-resourced care
sector to get women into the labor force
which is also an
engine for economic growth so absolutely
we need to fix these problems we need
better conditions we need to adjust
dress staffing
uh we need to have ppes everywhere just
basic protection
in or out of a pandemic environment um
and
this is gonna be uh you know this
involves more resources it involves
collective bargaining it involves
um getting allowing workers to have
an option to have a union um and this is
a reality for so many workers of the
world
so we think that um this has to happen
for the future otherwise
really the problems will become worse
indeed christy hoffman
general secretary at uniqlo union thank
you so much for your time
thank you well one of your questions is
also related to the working conditions
of health care workers
time to ask derek
covid19 is transmitted via aerosols so
why do healthcare workers wear all that
protective clothing
personal protective equipment or more
precisely shortages of it
has been an ongoing issue for for many
countries
since the start of this pandemic ppe
for healthcare workers includes a wide
range of gear
from masks to face shields
to gloves to gowns and the point
behind all of those products is to
provide a barrier
between what you want to keep out which
in this case is a respiratory pathogen
transmitted
primarily via aerosols through the air
and the person wearing the ppe however
cdc recommendations for people taking
care
of recovering covet 19 patients at home
don't include ones to wear head-to-foot
protective clothing
but only to wear effective masks and at
times
to put on single-use gloves healthcare
professionals
in hospital wards however are regularly
exposed to much higher levels of the
virus
than a caregiver at home soros kobe 2
can't enter the body directly through
the skin which provides
a very effective protective barrier um
but it can settle on it
and and remain capable of infecting
someone for a while
experts now believe that for the average
person
the chances of infecting yourself by
transferring the virus
from a surface where it's settled to
your face via your hands
um that that chance is actually quite
low but that danger is multiplied for
someone
who spends their days in a ward full of
coughing covet 19 patients so donning
items like gowns
and other protective clothing is an
important way to shield yourself
if you work with those people on a daily
basis